et j'aimerais vous dire un petit mot
puisque je quitte aujourd'hui télématin
j'aimerais remercier les téléspectateurs
qui m'ont suivi depuis de très
nombreuses années plus de 25 ans merci
pour votre fidélité
merci aux médecins merci aux malades qui
ont participé à mes reportages
merci aux équipes avec lesquelles j'ai
travaillé telus matin c'était une très
belle aventure et des belles aventures
j'espère qu'il y en aura d'autres
je vous donnerai des nouvelles sur les
réseaux sociaux alors voilà il ya un
vent de départ si ça les patins onze de
départ depuis le remplacement on se
cogne pas vu à l'assemblée matic de
cette émission qui dure depuis plus de
30 ans et donc je voulais m'adresser à
madame ernotte parce que je crois que
c'est un problème de dialogue c'est un
problème il faut il faut se parler
madame ernotte ses chroniqueurs sont des
gens formidables qui ont tout donné
pendant six mois l'emprise lancé allez
vas-y s'ils ont tout donné pendant 20
ans penser à patrick bruel qui a fait
jusqu'à 45% de parts de marché il est
normal de vouloir faire des économies
mais il méritait qu'on leur explique
qu'on leur parle
au lieu de ça ils ont reçu une lettre de
trois lignes leur proposant un cdi avec
30 ou 40 % de salaire en moins et aucune
assurance de garder le même emploi et
c'était ça ou la porte ça a été très
violent pour certains qui se sont
retrouvés à faire un procès à une
société qui l'ont servi qu'ils ont aimés
avec passion pendant 20 ans comme le
chantait reggiani il suffisait de
presque rien n'a pas de considération du
dialogue et on aurait vu la semaine
dernière des chroniques et on n'aurait
pas vu la semaine dernière des
chroniqueurs obligé de se mettre en noir
comme on vient de voir comme un appel au
secours silencieux alors évidemment il
ya des il ya des gens au chômage tous
les jours et tout ça mais c'est juste
une question de dialogue on est prêt je
suis venu parce que moi même je l' ai
vécu les émissions du matin c'est des
émissions de fond de grille on appelle
ça on ne dit jamais qu'on nous aime et
pourtant on fait des scores
exceptionnels et on donne beaucoup et
voilà et c'est on en arrive à ces
extrêmes faire des économies il le faut
mais pas dans ces conditions là
bourquin